[Music]
alright this of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show now so far hundreds literally
hundreds of challengers not one winner
we don't make mistakes like a well-oiled
machine yes yes Igor yes he was
practicing that all night long the
change that Swiss watch well anyway we
don't make mistakes well tonight
unbelievable a fan named Stephen Smoot
says he thinks that's a real name people
were giggling like how does Conan do it
that's his name a fan named Steven Smoot
says he thinks he caught a mistake he
says it happened during a recent comedy
bit check it out his video hi Conan this
is Steven from Provo Utah I noticed that
you made a really embarrassing mistake
and I'm here to correct you it was in
your bit about the lesser-known Star
Wars characters that are going to be cut
from the upcoming Disney movies there's
one point where you mispronounced the
name of this really important Star Wars
character
they pulled some products off the shelf
like Admiral Akbar brand flytraps
[Laughter]
so the name of the Mon Calamari Admiral
who fought for the Rebel Alliance at the
Battle of Endor is Akbar not Akbar as
you pronounced it but a proof that I'm
right I would like to direct your
attention to the scene in Return of the
Jedi where Mon Mothma is briefing the
rebel pilots in that scene
she clearly pronounces his name as Akbar
when she introduces him and not Akbar so
there's no way to cut it Conan you have
made a really really big blunder and you
need to correct it immediately
[Music]
Wow okay well before I go after the kid
I do want to congratulate him we've
never had anybody attached a GoPro to
his penis when they sent an amazing
innovative camerawork right where is he
by the way what is that he's gonna
supply closet are you and your AV closet
again are you in there talking about
Star Wars
well I'm sorry Steven but you are dead
wrong the character's name is pronounced
Akbar now maybe it was Akbar back in
1983 when the movie first came out but
any real star wars fan knows that George
Lucas went back and made changes to the
original trilogy here now is the
official Lucas approved version of the
scene you're talking about taken from
2011 s Star Wars The Complete Saga
blu-ray edition
many Bothans died to bring us this
information of Malak bar please Thank
You mon mothma
but actually the name is pronounced
Akbar the only reason I've agreed to
participate in this attack is because
Darth Vader insisted on mispronouncing
my name as Akbar
I will destroy Vader both for calling me
Akbar and for making fun of the way I
look I can still hear his cruel words to
this day I will Akbar and I do mean
Akbar look but a cloud in a giant frog
costume and now the leader of the attack
will be Lando Calrissian whose name
sound Armenian maybe Thank You Admiral
Akbar Akbar can you say it's a trap for
us No
[Applause]
[Music]
you spotted an error on our show report
it seemed koco.com / haha found an error
we will sort it out right here on the
air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make junk meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]